hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week cracking a smile on your face
this week we're talking about cmmc
control
ca.l2-3.12.3 monitor security controls
on an ongoing basis to ensure the
continued effectiveness of the controls
they told me to smile more when I did
this video I don't know I did one cut I
don't know apparently I look like
somebody ran over my dog or something
but anyway I'm smiling now because I'm
here with you we're hanging out we're
talking cmmc controls right let's get
into it
[Music]
all right so hey if you're a defense
contractor who's feeling overwhelmed
tired and alone trying to understand all
the cmmcd fars and nist SP 10171
compliance stuff on top of an already
colossal workload I got great news for
you you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance hero let's get into
it alright so uh on this control there's
only one thing that they're looking for
okay they're looking for help
determining if security controls are
monitored on an ongoing basis to ensure
the continued effectiveness of those
controls in other words
do you actually
have a method in place to monitor what
security is actually being implemented
because if you don't how would you know
that it's actually working so again if
we were to give a sample answer this we
would say hey it's implemented evidence
is available within the it tickets and
alert emails so again the it tickets are
sort of where things go when they need
to be remediated and then the emails the
email alerts are coming out of your
various monitoring systems like your
seam system maybe your sock maybe your
antivirus and other things that are sort
of directly sending information into
wherever you call Central home for
monitoring those things can be evidence
there and that's really kind of what
they're looking for on this control now
at oncall we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this dfars nist itar and cmmc compliance
stuff dropped into their laps like a
seal on a sunny day we teach you how to
level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your Company Limited
in gaps gray areas and getting it solved
all while showing you how to leverage
compliance as your secret weapon land
more Defense work with higher profit
margins now that's what becoming an
on-call compliance hero can do for you
if you're looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit cmmc
complianceeekers.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now I promise you don't have to struggle
anymore
and maybe then you'll be cracking a
smile anyway if you love the content
we're putting out here for you help us
out with a big thumbs up on that like
button or even better Hulk smash that
subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance learns roll it out until the
next combines tip my friends stay safe
and secure out there hit us in the
comments below to let you let us know
what you'd like to know more about when
it comes to information security and
compliance and I'll see you on the next
one
[Music]